Russia's war on Ukraine continues with
President zielinski making another plea
for arms to help his country the U.S and
its EU allies have bolstered his
military enabling it to fight back but
critics say that more weapons just means
that more people will die ears further
military aid for Ukraine the way forward
this is Inside Story
[Music]
hello there and welcome to the program
I'm Nastasia Tay now Russia's invasion
of Ukraine has brought war between two
European countries on a scale not seen
since World War II death and Destruction
has been extensive but Russia has been
met with stiff resistance and Ukrainian
forces have also retaken some territory
Western Arms and training have played a
key role forcing Russia to reassess its
tactics Moscow is now switching to
long-range weapons and drones some
critics of Western strategy say that
pouring more arms into a war simply
means more death and delays the need to
talk peace we'll be discussing all of
this with our guests very shortly but
first this report from Charles Stratford
in Ukraine on the latest wave there of
Russian attacks
[Music]
Torchlight guide Shoppers along the
shelves
Russia's almost nightly bombardment of
Ukraine's electricity and energy
infrastructure means millions of
ukrainians spend much of their daily
life in the dark
Toria is shopping with her
three-year-old son Daniel they fled
fighting near their home in the Harrison
region in April
the authorities tell us they've
stabilized the electricity situation and
then there's another attack it's been
like this for the last two months
he's got used to the darkness and
importantly he's not afraid we have no
choice we have to get through this
Emergency Services battled fires across
Kiev and various locations throughout
the country after another Russian
bombardment early Monday morning
this home was completely destroyed in a
village close to kievs by one of 30
so-called Kamikaze drones Ukrainian
military says it intercepted
it's scary thoughts of possibly becoming
homeless is terrifying everyone is
scared but we are bearing it
Maria and Denise have to carry their two
and a half year old son David up the
stairs to their apartment on the 13th
floor because electricity is down again
so the elevator doesn't work
ten days after the invasion as Russian
forces Advanced towards their apartment
Block in European they fled to the
Netherlands and then France they have
only recently returned
Maria Comforts her son in bed as she
tries to send him to sleep
Denise has put plastic sheeting over the
windows for additional protection
against the Sub-Zero winter temperatures
it's pretty hard but we try not to
complain because we think of our
soldiers living in the trenches in
dismal conditions but on one occasion we
didn't have electricity for two days
yes it's cold sometimes the child is
coughing it's winter but we can get
through this we wait for spring and
Victory
nearby is one of thousands of heated
tents with generators put up in recent
weeks where people can get warm and
charge their devices as work continues
around the clock to fully restore
electricity and heating across the
country
Russia's drone and missile attacks
targeting Ukraine's energy
infrastructure are happening with
increasing frequency and that means that
many people in neighborhoods like this
one face another night without Heating
and in the dark Charles Stratford Al
Jazeera Kiev
while Western military aid has been
critical to Ukraine's resistance and
Military advances let's take a closer
look at some of the numbers in total
more than 30 countries have provided
military equipment to Ukraine the U.S
has contributed the most by far with at
least 8.5 billion dollars in military
aid next on the list is Germany which is
given far less just over 2.34 billion
and the United Kingdom follows supplying
weapons worth 1.9 billion dollars but
Ukraine's president has appealed for
more funding saying that the monthly
cost of defense is about 5 billion
dollars
I ask you to increase the supply of air
defense systems to our country and help
speed up the relevant decisions of
Partners 100 air defense shield for
Ukraine will be one of the most
successful steps against Russian
aggression this step is needed right now
well for more on this I'm now joined by
all of our guests in Kiev we have Peter
zalnayev he's the executive director of
the Eurasia democracy initiative in
Moscow we have Pavel falgenhauer he's a
defense and Military analyst and in Riga
latviaz Leonid ragozen an independent
journalist and publisher of a book
called European tragedy a history of
Russia and the current conflict a warm
welcome to you all thank you so much for
joining us here on Inside Story we know
that Kiev has been coming under renewed
attacks in recent days so I'll start
there Peter presumably you'd like to see
more Western weapons then to help defend
your city
well indeed and this is this is
something that we've been obviously
warning about since at least October uh
the 10th which is the the day when the
first such strikes occurred you know
we're hearing very positive signals from
Washington that the Patriot air defense
system uh May finally be given to
Ukraine this should have been done weeks
if not months ago and it will still take
uh a while to train ukrainians to use it
because uh America cannot send its own
technicians to operate the most soldiers
that would be considered as uh
participation direct participation in
the War uh but this is a very
encouraging sign in Europe the West has
uh finally realized that
um you know Ukraine's defeat will be its
own defeat that another you know tens of
let's say millions of refugees flooding
over the borders to Europe will
overwhelm these societies will create a
significant uh uh problem for these
garments so uh you know they need to do
everything they can uh to help
ukrainians defend themselves from this
Terror from this guy that's been rained
on us for weeks weeks and weeks right
now I'm sitting here I'm lucky to have
power on but 80 of the key of region at
large is sitting now without power and
some of them without water well just
picking up on that Russia has obviously
been accused of weaponizing winter it's
Sub-Zero temperatures there we've been
seeing attacks on energy infrastructure
I know some defense analysts have been
suggesting that this might be a Russian
strategy to try to wear down
um Ukraine's air defense capability
because it takes so many arms in order
to try to defend itself Pavel do you
think that's the Russian plan here
although the Russian military have a
very substantial upper hand in that they
have capabilities to hit any Target in
any part of Ukraine long-range
capabilities that Ukraine does not
but the problem with this long-range
attack arm of the Russian military is
that they can hit only stationary
targets and big targets they can't hit a
mobile targets like say convoys or
trains bringing
reinforcements and weapons to the to the
front line and from the West
uh because Russian bombers don't venture
to fly deep into Ukraine at all that
means these are long-range missiles that
hit stationary targets the most easy
stationary Target are the Ukrainian grid
system that me and also defense industry
and also military camps but basically
right now it's democracy power stations
but not of course the
nuclear ones but those are but those
that are producing electric power hoping
that nine electric power to Ukraine will
put enough pressure on the Ukrainian
government to seek a peaceful solution
to seek a ceasefire Russia right now
very much needs a ceasefire
for one several years at least
but the ceasefire on Russian terms so
this is how they're putting pressure
that we they can't do it and they are
doing it well if they're trying to put
pressure on it it seems to be backfiring
somewhat because these attacks have only
really strengthened morale we've seen
that in in quite a lot of the polling
that's been coming out of Kiev I know
ukrainians are saying the majority of
them that they're resolved to now fight
until Victory so trying to end the war
especially at this point seems to be not
the not the aim here ukrainians feel
like they're making gains they want the
war to continue Leonard let me throw
this to you that sounds like an argument
for more weapons from the west then well
I suppose so and it's uh it's not
inconsiderable that more weapons are
supplied by the Western Ukraine will
result in success on the battlefields
and and Ukraine being able to recapture
at least the territory that was captured
by Russia after February 24th after the
startup they pull out uh Invasion uh
however it is equally not inconsiderable
about that there will be no success and
that the um missile strikes against the
Ukrainian uh power grid will result in
something that came to humanitarian
catastrophe uh towards towards the end
or towards the middle of the winter
um so it's it's a very very complicated
equation uh that intelligent services
and the military
um in Western countries need to solve
and to to make a very accurate forecast
because the the cost of inaccurate
forecast is human lives and many many
human lives thousands and thousands of
course but also not just more weapons I
believe that Kiev is asking for but also
more sophisticated Weaponry is there
potentially a risk do you think Pavel of
an escalation into potentially NATO
territory if more sophisticated weapons
are sent
although Ukraine is asking for
sophisticated weapons is getting a
sophisticated weapons since the War
Began in the end of February uh the
Ukrainian military now have capabilities
they didn't have in the beginning of the
war and capabilities with some of them
that Russia also does not have
and that has changed the overall balance
in the beginning or the first half of
this conflict up to the mid-summer maybe
Russia had the initiative and the upper
hand though there were many
mistakes made and many disasters
happened but still now the equation has
changed now Ukraine has the initiative
to some extent and that's right means
that there's going to be more fighting
and the fighting will get more severe
may be actually next month we'll see a
major winter battle developing there at
which that's what many military
experts in Russia and in Ukraine are
predicting and this may be a decisive
battle for the future of this part of
the world or maybe not of course we
don't know for sure but both sides are
gearing up for that conflict coming up
and Gathering reserves oh Pablo it
sounds like you're talking about an
escalation there so let me ask you Peter
someone sitting in Kiev now is there a
concern that more weapons could result
in a further escalation potentially even
raise the nuclear threat I mean
obviously some threats were made back in
October well the nuclear threat is
something that we I would prefer to sort
of uh bracket simply because we just you
know this is uh the Doomsday scenario
none wants to contemplate it seems
plausible that the Chinese counterparts
have made it clear to Vladimir Putin in
recent meetings that they will not
countenance the use of nuclear weapons
and so that is being relied on as a
potential deterrent obviously there's no
guarantee of that but if we simply just
do not consider that if we're talking
about conventional Weaponry like I'm not
a military expert uh but uh you know
when we talk about escalation that two
Ukrainian years at least sounds a little
ridiculous we're in the midst of uh the
biggest European land-based War since
World War II uh Russia is already doing
all it can to uh to terrorize us uh
Vladimir Putin has made very clear his
goal and that is The Disappearance of
Ukraine as a sovereign entity as a state
you know sometimes the Western audience
or worldwide audience does not
understand the implications that does
not understand the message I mean all
you have to do is just uh understand
some Russian to tune into these Federal
TV channels uh and to to hear every day
uh uh these uh calls for ukrainians to
be exterminated for Ukrainian children
to be drowned in rivers this is third
third right rhetoric this is what Hitler
said about Jews there's really no
difference this is a genocidal war and
uh you know yeah I agree with Bible the
future of the rest of the 21st century
and our security
um architecture is being decided in
Ukraine I think and I hope the West
understands
there's obviously a lot of rhetoric
flying around but I do want to ask you a
very basic question which I'm sure a lot
of our viewers are trying to work out at
the moment I think fundamentally people
see more weapons being sent and they
presumed that will mean the fighting
will continue for longer and as a result
the fighting continues more lives are
lost and there's more destruction of
your country and there's obviously been
hundreds of billions of dollars worth of
Destruction already and you're living
through and suffering through all of
that now is there the appetite for that
to continue is there not a worry that
this will just go on indefinitely well
if weapons are not being sent to Ukraine
that that means capitulation of Ukraine
and that's not an option to us who are
ukrainians and who do not want to be a
part of Russia uh you know 98 of
ukrainians now want restoration to 1991
borders when we talk about this kind of
weaponry and long-range missiles that
would be uh giving Ukraine symmetrical
ability to strike at military targets
inside Russia including those missile
launchers from the Caspian Sea which
Russia is using to terrorize civilians
and that's what we're talking about okay
I want to broaden this out a little bit
because this is a war that's obviously
had huge impacts not just on Ukraine but
also many other countries around the
globe when it comes to food security
Energy prices economic crises and in
various different places could more
weapons do you think Leonid prolonged
the suffering for everyone and might
that give other countries the impetus to
try to resolve this in a different way
well um again I would say that that
depends on the accuracy of the forecasts
associated with the supplies of those
weapons because if if this war drags on
for a long time then yes there'll be an
impact on on the whole on the whole
world on the um on the European economy
and on the on the economy globally
um so I'm sure that Western governments
are taking this into a consideration and
then also yes there's the nuclear risk
which should not be exaggerated however
we are talking about a very uh
non-transparent group a very small group
that is ruled in Russia that is
controlling uh this huge arsenal of
nuclear weapons which is capable of
destroying entire Humanity really
um so it should be a concern for
Humanity
um
so
um yes on the one hand it is a adjust
course to arm and support Ukraine but
also all these considerations
regarding the the future of the voters
really or the future of humanity I
should be also taken into account we
don't know whether uh is a suicidal
person whether he's Entourage or
suicidal as well I want to turn to some
of the pressure that's been mounting on
different Western countries involved
here particularly the US I I see that
just in the last few weeks Russia pulled
out of the new start treaty talks the
the um their agreement to reduce nuclear
arms and they're trying to ramp up
pressure clearly on Washington in order
to stop supporting Ukraine Pavel do you
think that's working at all
well Russia is using of course the
nuclear deterrent fully as a deterrent
that's for what nuclear weapons were
made to use them as a deterrent meaning
to employing words that's nuclear
blackmail
but the difference between using them as
a deterrent and using them actually
using them that's well that's the
so-called nuclear threshold and it is
very high so right now it doesn't seem
that anyone would want to go over that
threshold because that goes both ways if
you use nuclear weapons you're going to
receive nuclear weapons from the other
side because both sides have the turrets
there so that's a kind of this uh
nuclear returns that Russia is using
against the West is modifying the
Western support for Ukraine Ukraine is
not getting long-range the missiles to
attack deep into Russian most likely
won't because that is seen as too
provocative
a Ukraine is getting Battlefield weapons
most likely defense weapons uh to
against Russian long-range attacks like
anti-missile anti-aircraft additional
capabilities uh which will more or less
keep the situation as it is for or
something like that sure
yes I just want to bring in Pisa here
because we're talking about the US
continuing to send weapons to Ukraine as
Kiev and zelensky have requested but I'm
curious Pisa at what point do you see
those weapons stop because President
Biden at some point in March he had some
unscripted remarks that hinted at regime
change in the Kremlin but we've really
had no clear objective from the US in
terms of of what they want to achieve
here so if you're sending weapons to
Ukraine and you're the us at what point
do you stop
well you know I think it has a momentum
of its own you know contrary to fear so
initial fears that the Trump
republican-controlled Congress cut uh
Aid Ukraine drastically it hasn't
happened through the Trump wing of the
party hasn't uh really had much of a
showing uh and meanwhile you know the
military industrial complex uh of the US
is ramping up uh its uh production
capacity its budget has been increased
uh by Congress so
um the momentum is still to continue
this uh support of Ukraine not without
issues not without problems and
qualifications but until
2024 until the new presidential
elections I think the inertia will uh
maintain simply because
um speaking of the population shaking of
uh just a public opinion of the support
of you in the US remains overwhelming
well there is also public support for
peace talks in various different places
so I want to turn to that Moscow has a
narrative that Ukraine is the one that
doesn't want to negotiate but from what
I understand Russia is demanding that
Ukraine recognize geopolitical realities
I say that with quotation marks and
before coming to the table so by my
understanding in order to sit down
Moscow requires Kiev to make concessions
Leonard is that essentially giving
things away before you even start
negotiating
the way I see it the strategical of the
Kremlin is to essentially to punish
Ukraine for refusing to implement Minsk
agreements and to punish it in general
for being intrans engine so in that
sense
um it doesn't really matter for the
Kremlin I think
um what uh what what percentage of the
territory currently controls will be
left read after after the settlement
what's what's important for them I think
is that Ukraine loses more than it had
before February 24th and that that
answer includes the control of the the
parts
companions that Russia currently
controls and and also for Russia it will
be very difficult to part with the land
Corridor to Crimea which they have
gained by a position
but all the rest is I think negotiable
for the Kremlin and any any solution
that will involve keeping those parts of
logansk and to the nearest Regions and
the land Corridor to Crimea
all of this can be presented by the
Kremlin as a victory at the end of the
day of course well one of the most
powerful arguments that I've heard for
making the West to continue its support
of Ukraine has been around precedent so
they're saying well number of analysts
are saying that Western Powers need to
stay the course to continue providing
weapons and not necessarily push for
peace talks right now because what you
want to do is prevent future escalation
on the next Crisis otherwise moscow's
really presented a blueprint for not
only Russia but for other potential
powers to get what they want from the
west and Pavel what do you make of that
argument
well many in the west especially in
Europe would want to see a ceasefire
happening and Moscow once a ceasefire
right now because the Ukrainian right
now have more men in their armed forces
and in many cases have more weapons and
the Russia right now is struggling to
replace the weapons and Munitions we're
using up the intensity of the fighting
is high and then I think that Russia can
continue for a long time most likely
Ukraine also wants to ceasefire but
again it's about the terms sure uh what
Russia wants a freeze of what that
there's more or less a freeze of these
status quo for the time being a line of
control established a kind of Minsk
three Ukraine is not ready for that and
that means and the West is not ready to
put any kind of real pressure on Ukraine
though of course they're holding back
say uh long range missiles that could be
used from the high Marsh system for 300
kilometers the Americans are not giving
that and the others are also not giving
it because these these missiles are in
other NATO countries so there is some
pressure on the ukrainians but no one
wants to be seen as the one who forces
the ukrainians into a capitulation so
right now I believe both sides actually
have enough weapons there on the
battlefield for one more very vicious
battle coming up in the winter then
there's going to be spring and that
means a lot of month and there's going
to be a pause and then there's going to
be summer by summer maybe we'll have a
ceasefire maybe not it depends how the
coming battles turn out on the
battlefield that's where the decision is
going to be made indeed and we'll
continue watching that all very closely
here on altazira but for now thank you
to all of our guests Peters almayev
Leonid rogozin and Pablo falgenhauer
thanks so much for joining us and thank
you too for watching you can see the
program again anytime by visiting our
website that's aljazeera.com and for
further discussion do go to our Facebook
page that's facebook.com forward slash
AJ Inside Story you can also join the
conversation on Twitter our handle is at
AJ Inside Story for me anastasiote and
the whole team here in Doha bye for now
[Music]